she's created like there's a bunch of
YouTube people that do that they're
doing like these weird YouTube videos
yeah there's so many people doing it now
yeah but it's like he but he's found and
like a real specifically funny niche
because he's because he's real to the
characters like a lot of times the
people are throwing characters together
in sketches and they're just kind of so
cheaply done and they don't have any
like they don't mean comedic bass
they're just like weird to be [ __ ]
goofy and it's like right you gotta have
some kind of bass man there's a few
people that do it right my kid loves
this lady Miranda sings do you know that
is she's this she's got this show called
[ __ ] which don't picture Miranda sings
yeah I think that's her name isn't in
her name what does she do I tried to get
her in the podcast do not respond at all
that's so try to do it just for my
daughter she's so into this lady's show
but it's a show that's not for kids yeah
that's her it's a weird show like the
show yeah she had a Netflix show yeah
they gave her I canceled it I don't know
if it was a movie or a show actually I
my [ __ ] kid loved that show and I was
I was watching it where the kinda movie
went yeah what is that haters back back
off that's what it's called haters back
off is that a movie or a show it's a
show yeah play the trailer whole thing
you laughed you I'm sure this time I'm
sure you'll be fine
Miranda right now you're just a boring
famous person we need to get you to
please great its where legends are born
legends my daughter who's eight will do
an impression not gone mermaids were
real she likes she does that voice that
voice that she does but it's a show like
it's almost like a tim and eric' type
show it's not really a show for
eight-year-olds it's just a mindfuck
show yeah so I'm like letting her watch
it and like I don't even think you
should be watching us but then again she
lives with me he had no [ __ ] I'm just
gonna say what did you watch the you
know you shouldn't have been watching
when you were a kid today I tried to not
swear for the first five years of their
life and then I'm like impossible stop
my wife would get me I'm like what are
they gonna learn about something early
he has a [ __ ] I'm nice I'll just beeps
occasionally I say [ __ ] or [ __ ] what's
the big deal I don't say like I'm gonna
[ __ ] you to my wife I'm gonna [ __ ] you
lady I don't say that your kids are
eating dinner I'm gonna [ __ ] you lady
night I'm [ __ ] you guys your mom
[ __ ] ghetto I made you do daddies
you're upset it's how I [ __ ] made you
that's where you came from
Mike